Comics logic is an online portal to
discover meaning in a Labyrinth of
biological data
it's an online community for top
researchers and Professionals in
bioinformatics to supply universities
and other organizations with online
courses certifications and practical
case studies in biomedical data analysis
spanning the Journey of a novice to
develop skills and stand out from the
crowd we provide access to asynchronous
resources specialized training
mentorship and Big Data infrastructure
as a result students learn about
meaningful application of computational
skills to relevant data sets in their
chosen domain in this way we address the
pressing challenge that slows down the
effective analysis of large data sets
produced in research and biotechnology
industry
we addressed the topic of software
complexity the need for big data
processing power access to tested
methods by experts in the field exposure
to real-world challenges and training
for faculty to stay updated even beyond
their area of expertise
to do so we first address the topic of
materials for courses that are usually
developed in-house taught sporadically
in a rarely updated
so we opened up the omics logic portal
to a dynamic community that will
introduce new materials and keep them up
to date with the newest technology all
the time
secondly these courses have to be
organized and because the challenge is
to combine several different topics
together the flow and transitions
between subjects has to be improved this
is addressed at omic's logic through
introductory materials being woven
throughout the courses
finally let's talk about systematization
these topics are extremely complex so
there's a need to know that someone is
stuck and needs help or allow another
one to run forward and so to address
this omixlogic uses standardized modules
and interactive sessions that begin with
mastering terminology and Concepts to
then implementing these concepts with
real data sets in a case study approach
so the portal brings Community Driven
experience to anyone to learn how to
analyze biological data build up their
profile to be ready for research
industry or entrepreneurship using
biotechnology and Big Data the features
are designed to make this process
seamless for individual users a class or
a whole Institution
the Onyx logic portal gives students
options for analyzing any data
codependent or independent paths these
data sets and Associate Publications can
be used in several ways you can learn
bioinformatics without any coding at all
for that in each project we explain the
analysis pipelines on the user-friendly
TBI info platform for Big Data analysis
you can also learn the scripts behind
many of the steps learning to Wrangle
clean visualize and analyze data in
popular languages like R and python in
order to create your own analyzes
finally you can hear about the projects
and the research applications in our
Mentor guided programs where experts
share their experience and support
research projects developed by you
so this is not just a portal with online
courses or moocs
this is a community where you can see
achievements progress certification and
explore projects developed by students
having access to Big Data analysis tools
with interactive outputs in a logical
flow help students master and understand
complex bioinformatics processes
designed by experts and produce outputs
that are both intuitive and biologically
interpretable
in addition students can learn practice
solve computational problems and
discover opportunities as they go
through intuitive learning using our
coding console with predefined answers
that can be obtained by manipulating the
code having expert designed training
opportunities students can design job
ready skills and find job opportunities
in the Academia industry as an intern or
even by finding a short-term project
this approach allows any student to
develop a profile that stands out
Onyx logic was designed in collaboration
with top universities and as a result we
have a team of experts that are guiding
the development of the necessary
resources managed by a team that is
distributed across several locations
like North America India and Africa
in each one of these locations we have
established Partnerships with top
institutions that represent community
colleges universities
high schools and organizations that
support biomedical research